as I mentioned we're about to have a
look at it partly reviews so I'm going
to get you guys can help me to remember
the fact that but you have the equation
of a line there are actually lots of
different equations that can represent
the same line
there are different forms you can put
the equation in some of which are more
useful than others or they're useful for
different purposes so I want you to help
you remember what are these calls one
that you should look at and recognize
and know what they are and why they're
useful let's start with some really big
ones before we get to the ball broadly
applicable ones horizontal and vertical
lines come in a format you or to
recognize if you have a horizontal line
if the equation will be in what form y y
equals and I mean in this case we'll
just put like a letter like these person
I choose B because we in quarter
geometry we tend to mean me as the as
the Y visit which we'll come to in a
second right well Y cuisine obviously
intersects with the y axis as big what
about a vertical one this is y equals so
vertical one would be x equals what
letter would you like talk B I'm going
to Julian I'm nice an alphabetical in
parallel so for each of these a and B
are constants so why do you have some
number over there on the right hand side
you'll get a horizontal line or a
vertical line but as we know most minds
I'm not perfectly horizontal or
perfectly vertical they're off at angles
so now we do a whole bunch of different
forms really I can throw at me break
your champion okay general form okay
general has our 1 2 3 characteristics
that make it what it is for the first
thing the right hand side an equal to
something specific 0 I start with this
one because it's a unique quality about
general form what are you lookin a ax
plus B Y Z plus C ok now the first
characteristic is at the right hand side
of 0 everything else is shoves on the
left hand side what are the
characteristics what keeps really got
say a B and C what kinds of numbers do
we we tend to make them we tend to make
them integers right we want them nice
and whole it's easier to write so a B
and C are whole in particular a just as
a conviction we want this to not just be
an integer but we tend to like it
positive right
even though same thing we can multiply
through the whole thing by negative 1
since that going 0 that's the same line
but that way at least you're consistent
and if I say get in general form you're
all like the same equation because
general form is fine it's like a useful
geometrically go you can't look at that
and know any of the features on your
line so someone give me another form
gradient gradient intercept or slope
intercept form now this one is a bit
easier to work with visually because
once you read off the equation the great
is there as a number and so is Earth if
it's a y-intercept right but great why
does that fall down the wrong path on
the same way what is it
y equals ok you can recognize the
gradient you can recognize the
y-intercept which is why I chose this ok
so far so good
we know more than this code right
someone give me another one give me
another one
let me give you a clue gradient
intercept is one of them there's another
which or even unit forget on point
gradient point granules energy wonderful
I will come to chip away for a second
what is we're grateful
one run apply minus of y1 yeah now quite
greedy it goes straight to 2 point
formula because if you take em and you
recognize that we have a formula for M
that is in terms of two points right if
you just substitute the greedy formula
in there but what is the greater value y
y2 minus y1 mine x2 minus x1 if you
check that guy here and then just
rearrange a tiny bit then two points it
just kind of plopped out right because
look the left-hand side is already y -1
1 u divided by X minus x1 nice to get
these guys all gathered here on the
left-hand side and what do you get on
the right-hand side what's left the
gradient right which what did we just
say is rise over run hey yeah
so you see how this flows out on this
register slightly frames what do you
think is that a reasonably complete list
now you know looks alright to me
ok there is one more of an odd road you
add on to this which is very useful it
flows straight on from 2.4 and again
like Brady intercept form which is for
the most common one you seen before it's
very useful visually ok it's not to
point for it to intercept all it's quite
seldom used but anyone know what to
intercept for me
general falls you make the right hand
side zero to get to intercept form you
make the right hand side one okay now
because this is unfamiliar let me show
you how this works let's call with a
line how about 5x minus 2y plus what's a
nice number that we can choose how that
pepper equal Z here it is in general
form and as we point out before you know
almost nothing to cut this line like a
lead straight away of course you can
work it out but it's not immediately
obvious here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to rearrange this such that it
looks like this okay so I want the
constant term to be on the right hand
side and I want it to be 1 so what shall
I do
more like major is the first step the
contents on the left right here
maybe I should subtract it from both
sides you get on the right so that's
going to look like this you right yeah
okay so now I want to get towards 1 so
it's negative 10 right now so I'm just
going to divide it through by negative
10 we divided that through you better
divide everything else as well that okay
all right let's just simplify this out a
little bit I mean this is an awkward way
to write up and you see the advantage
very quickly we almost never ask you to
have negatives on the denominator but
negative the Denyer actually really
useful in this case what are you going
to get here if you simplify this and
have an X on the top it'll be native to
on the bottom just watch out here what's
this going to be double negative so this
is plus y on five and then there's the
one that we're after yes
okay I wonder if he knows write down
what it's called this how do you find
the x intercepts for instance of a line
how do you find it epicenter you let y
equal zero
so nothing zero sorry that's going to
become this plus what great so now you
solve well there's just the one on the
right-hand side right so X is going to
be equal to surprise surprise
and if you repeat this process you let X
equal zero
what do you think with the virtual line
right there so this is really nice this
is a great form because you know what
anytime you draw a line on the corner
axis what are the three points we expect
every time you label on this three of
them what's the most important point on
the whole date
the origin is the first point one of the
other two yeah this intercept let's call
that negative two and that intercept one
two three four five there it is
so if I know what the intercepts are
then I immediately have the line and you
can get gradient out about different
walls okay but what is the gradient you
can read it off this country its rise
everyone is five over two careful it's
gone up I know that this is negative two
but the leg the run is just to write
because to help as you should expect to
be point yeah okay now when do you use
one form like I've got one two three
four five to choose from are these two
obviously your leaves in the special
cases when do you choose one over
another one for example why would you
use gradient stepping why would you
start off
presenter final answer well if they
asked you to present a final nation they
say nothing I would actually call me
default - this one is called gel form
after all you can put any light in this
form
I probably use this board if you want to
know say for instance an insurance
parallel their parallel parallel or
perpendicular what pieces emission is
going to help you answer that medium
right have a look at the list here
there's only two that require or include
the gradient right and we're going to go
for this one
there's no point why why would I use
this when I can just go into the
gradient there okay well in that case
why would you use this one but it's
quite gradient form useful if you are
supplied appointees and they tell your
gradient and then off you go okay so
often the form that you use is defined
by what information do I have access to
sometimes that's obvious other times
it's not so obvious I bother reference
sheet that I showed you before do you
remember I sort of move to this
perpendicular distance formula it
requires this form right they won't tell
you you have to get into that wall you
just have to recognize oh they can enter
B and C in that formula it's these two
energies that make sense what about my
code